[Musique]
laurence rochât bienvenus bonjour
bienvenue pour ce café politique qui va
nous permettre d'en savoir un petit peu
plus sur vous vous êtes né en 73 élus
d'opposition à guyancourt vous êtes
conseiller départemental donc des
yvelines membre du bureau politique
aussi la des républicains responsable
yvelinoise du mouvement sens commun
voilà ont débuté un mot sur votre
famille politique
comment se portent les républicains pour
vous mais les républicains sont dans une
démarche de refondation qui a été
initiée voilà depuis déjà un moment avec
un rapport qui qui est sorti le rapport
de la refondation de la droite et ce
nouvel élan qui était donné par par
laurent wauquiez donc je découvre un peu
plus de l'intérieur ce mouvement
maintenant que je siège au bureau
politique
il y aura d'ailleurs le 13 mars une
prochaine une prochaine réunion
aujourd'hui pour vous laurent wauquiez
c'est l'homme de la situation
laurent wauquiez c'est celui qui parmi
les militants est ressorti avec une
large majorité comme celui qui était à
même de mener ce projet de la droite
alors après vous savez au sein d'une
famille politique c'est comme dans une
famille classique je dirais il ya des
personnalités il ya des fortes têtes
il ya des ya parfois des désaccords qui
peuvent porter soit sur le fond soit sur
la forme mais certains ont fait le choix
quitter aussi certaines querelles de
baronnie nouvel an l'adhésion moment
exactement et au sein de cette famille
politique et bahia place justement pour
un débat d'idées est toujours justement
une écoute aussi de ce que la base a
envie de faire de faire remonter et
encore une fois ce rapport de la
refondation de la droite clarifie
énormément cette cette ligne que les
militants souhaitent souhaite mettre en
oeuvre
ça signifie quoi aujourd'hui être
membre des républicains être de droite
aux républicains ça signifie faire
partie de pirey d'une famille comme je
le disais tout à l'heure avec ce souci
d'être enfin de proposer aux français
une alternative au projet de monsieur
macron qui soi-disant n'est ni de droite
ni de gauche qui empruntent
effectivement à ces deux courants et est
fondamentalement c'est aussi se reposer
la question qu'est ce que la droite et
qu'est ce que la droite que nous voulons
et je pense qu'on a tous le travail à
faire de clarification de la ligne
programmatique pour être en mesure dans
les prochaines échéances électorales de
proposer aux adhérents ou militants
voilà un projet parce qu'il faut faire
revenir ses adhérents ont parlé des
ténors politiques ont fait le choix de
partir mais il ya aussi ses adhérents
qui qui eux se posent des questions ne
serait ce que dans le département des
yvelines jacques tous aujourd'hui les
rangs on était un peu décimés on a eu en
2010 est une année électorale très riche
où on a vu quand même une belle
mobilisation
on a vu aussi des adhérents qui sont
devenus des militants c'est à dire des
personnes qui pour l'instant peut-être
avait seulement leur carte mais qui
n'étaient pas prêtes à je dirais à se
mouiller le samedi matin au sens propre
comme au sens figuré pour aller sur un
marché où pour aller distribuer des
tracts à la sortie d'une gare en semaine
et on a vu cette cette énergie que le
que la droite était capable de susciter
et je pense qu'effectivement se calme un
petit peu en ce moment c'est aussi le
temps de la réflexion c'est le temps de
cette refondation qui nécessite de
mettre à plat
un projet qui a ensuite pour un motivé
justement des adhérents voilà à
poursuivre leur engagement politique
quelle qu'en soit la forme
votre engagement a débuté avec sens
commun alors il n'a pas débuté avec sens
comment il a débuté en 2014 lorsque
effectivement ladislas kourak était tête
de liste à guyancourt m'a proposé de
rejoindre son équipe
et à l'époque je n'étais pas encartés
comme on dit voilà j'ai rejoint son
équipe parce que il portait un projet
qu'il avait une personnalité qui voilà
qui donnait envie de le suivre et c'est
comme ça que je suis entré en politique
l'engagement sens commun est venu un peu
plus tard quand justement je me suis
rendu compte que faire de la politique
c'est ptet pas c'était pas un travail
qu'on pouvait mener seul et que c'était
important justement de rejoindre un
courant de pensée voire même une famille
politique comme je le disais tout à
l'heure et
et à l'époque c'était l'ump voilà et
j'ai découvert en ce sens commun ce
mouvement qui est né en 2013 une volonté
je dirais de réconcilier justement le
peuple de droite avec peut-être une une
comment dire une structure qui qui
n'était pas forcément toujours à
l'écouté et il y avait chez sens comme
un set cette volonté vraiment de
réaffirmer aussi des idées de droite
avec notamment la nécessité d'offrir un
cadre pour penser des progrès
scientifiques économiques sociaux aussi
en ayant toujours à coeur le souci de la
personne humaine et notamment des plus
faibles et ça c'est un sujet qui voilà
qui a qui a résonné en moi et j'ai
apprécié aussi chez eux cette cette
manière de faire de la politique
autrement notamment en faisant monter
une nouvelle génération des personnes
issues de la société civile puisque mon
effectivement je n'avait jusqu'à présent
pas côtoyer le monde politique même si
je m'y étais intéressé puisque j'ai fait
des études de philosophie politique sens
commun pour repréciser pour les gens qui
ne connaissent pas c'est un mouvement
qui est déclinée de la manif pour tous
non sens commun c'est un mouvement qui
qui est né au même moment effectivement
que se montrer les gens qui se sont
engagés au sein de la manif pour tous au
sein de sens commun avec une vision
plutôt de droite catholique
traditionnelle en gagnent eux il ya de
tout dans ce sens commun c'est à dire
que c'est pas un parti confessionnel
c'est parti à confessionnelles on ne
demande pas de certificat de baptême ou
de deux certificats d'appartenance à une
religion quelconque et il ya de toute
façon dans ce sens comment plusieurs
plusieurs religions représenter
j'imagine en tout cas ça n'est pas un
mouvement labellisé catholique
c'est un mouvement qui est né
effectivement dans la foulée des
mouvements sociétaux de la manif pour
tous voilà
mais avec non pas une orientation on va
dire d'être un lobby d'être d'être un
think tank mais d'être vraiment un
mouvement politique est en ce sens un
mouvement politique ça s'intéressent à
tous les sujets ça s'intéresse pas
uniquement à la question du mariage pour
tous comme le faisait la manif pour tous
soyez donc c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
la même démarche
après les valeurs aujourd'hui de sens
commun alors les valeurs aujourd'hui de
sens commun c'est ce que je vous
rappeler tout à l'heure c'est à dire cet
attachement à un engagement politique
d'abord qui soit celui d'élus qui voilà
qui reçoivent un mandat au service du
bien commun et non pas avec une volonté
peut-être de d'acquérir des postes ou de
douala ii de briller mais vraiment cette
cette idée qu'on est au service
il ya notamment cette notion de
transmission qui nous habitent c'est à
dire qu'elle est finalement le pays que
nous allons laisser aux générations aux
générations futures donc vraiment cette
cette idée qu'un engagement politique
sans racines dans la durée et au service
du bien commun
et puis il ya effectivement un socle
programmatique qui est consultable en
ligne sur sur le site de sens commun un
socle programmatique avec on va dire
justement un pool
très lié effectivement aux sujets
sociétaux c'est à dire la famille
l'éducation tout ce qui est de l'ordre
de la transmission voilà et puis aussi
une grande importance liés à l'écologie
qu'on lit d'ailleurs à l'économie parce
que ça peut être deux sujets qui peuvent
à première vue ne pas avoir forcément de
rapport mais finalement il ya une
économie à mettre en place aussi au
service de notre de notre société mais
aussi au service de notre pays de notre
monde plus généralement et avec au coeur
de cette préoccupation qu'elle soit
celle de l'écologie qu'elle soit celle
de l'économie la question de la personne
humaine
mais sur la ligne politique sur la ligne
de droite qui est défendue à un moment
l'ancien responsable de sens commun lui
n'était pas contre une alliance avec
marion maréchal-le pen par exemple alors
ça c'est quelque chose qui a été qui a
été interprétée par ceux effectivement
l'ancien président christophe briand a
parlé d'une plate-forme dé droite
et encore une fois une plateforme qui a
pour but je dirais de faire ce
brainstorming des idées voyez mais pour
autant la position de sens comment elle
est très très clairs sens commun est un
mouvement au sein des républicains oddo
prosit et avec d'autres formations
politiques
évidemment qu'on discute avec comme
comme n'importe quel comme n'importe
quel élu on peut discuter avec avec des
personnes qui ne sont pas entre
guillemets de notre bord qui en tout cas
ne sont pas sur la même ligne
donc la discussion est toujours possible
avec avec d'autres élus qui qui sont
engagés dans d'autres mouvements mais la
position de sens commun est très clair
c'est un mouvement au sein des
républicains vous parliez tout à l'heure
de du fait que vous étiez que vous
découvriez on est la société civile la
politique au civil ou sept professeurs
vous continuer cet été
non je l'étais pas ce que j'ai fait le
choix ensuite de me consacrer à
l'éducation de mes enfants
et donc je n'ai pas repris mon activité
d'enseignante et aujourd'hui c'est la
politique qui occupe 100 % de votre
activité de votre temps à 100% que les
100% parce que j'ai encore des enfants
qui voient là qui ont besoin de moi
j'estime que l'on peut pas à la fois
défendre les valeurs familiales et ne
pas s'occuper de sa propre famille donc
il ya un équilibre subtil à trouver
entre les deux caisses qui me fit qui
vous motive aujourd'hui dans ce combat
politique
sachant que la politique aujourd'hui
c'est un monde difficile je pense que ce
qui motive c'est de me dire que je suis
là dans un dans un mandat dans deux
mandats qui m'ont été confiées que j'ai
pas le droit de mal les assumer et donc
mon premier objectif c'est celui-là
c'est de mener à bien les missions qui
m'ont été confiées en étant élu
d'opposition à guyancourt en étant élu
au sein de la majorité du département
ce combat pour la famille c'est
c'est la ligne directrice de votre
combat politique c'est un des aspects
effectivement qui me motive aujourd'hui
et aujourd'hui je siège à la commission
des affaires familiales sociales et de
l'emploi au département des yvelines
et c'est vrai qu'à travers les projets
que nous menons nous sommes aussi
confrontés je dirais aux détresses qui
sont celles de voilà que nous pouvons
rencontrer dans les yvelines mais pas
que et je reste très attaché
effectivement aux solutions et au projet
qu'on peut mener en faveur des plus
faibles
et c'est bien vu par votre famille
justement cet engagement politique oui
c'est bien vu parce que je pense qu'il
ya d'abord au sein d'un groupe comme
comme celui de des yvelines voilà une
volonté de travailler ensemble avec en
même temps cette conscience que chacun
de nous apporte peut-être sa spécificité
dans la construction d'édifices mais il
ya des relations cordiales et amicales
entre nous il ya quelquefois une
déception lorsque l'on vient de la
société civile etc on se confronte à la
réalité du pouvoir maintenant que vous
siégez au sein de la majorité du conseil
départemental de ne pas pouvoir tout
faire de se faire entendre
est ce que vous l'avez ressenti un
moment je pense que d'abord quand on est
une jeune élue on découvre dans un
premier temps on découvre on découvre
seulement découvre des procédures etc
donc il ya tout un temps d'apprentissage
et là je trouve que d'ailleurs ce qui
est précieux et c'est là encore que je
fais référence à la famille politique il
ya ce temps aussi voyez de de parrainage
et on a la chance dans les yvelines et
plus spécifiquement aussi sur sur 50 ans
d'avoir des des des personnes qui sont
engagées en politique depuis plus
longtemps je pense à michel laugier je
pense à jean michel fourgous qui ont
joué aussi pour nous ce rôle voilà de
nous aider à mettre le pied à l'étrier
d'être là pour nous donner des conseils
techniques pour nous aider sur des
dossiers etc et on retrouve au sein de
du groupe ensemble pour les yvelines
cette cette belle dynamique de travail
collectif
ça veut dire que pour vous ce n'est que
le début de votre engagement c'est un
engagement qui se fait dans la durée
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
parce que la politique effectivement ne
permet pas de résoudre du jour au
lendemain
un des problèmes des sujets qui méritent
réflexion
à un moment plus jeune vous vous étiez
dit je m'engagerai en politique non je
m'étais pas tu te dis ça je mettais pas
dit ça même si je connaissais un petit
peu ce monde politique mais côté
services puisque j'avais un papa qui
travaille dans l'administration
à titre personnel non c'était pas c'est
un progrès on va dire c'est vraiment né
de cette rencontre en 2002 début 2014
avec ladislas courant et vous avez des
ambitions en politique alors belles
ambitions comme je vous le disais
d'abord de bien remplir mes mandats de
me tenir disponible pour aurait pour les
voilà sur sa candidature il ya des
européennes y aura des législatives un
le cycle politique des élections va
revenir c'est déjà je pense que ce qui
est important dans cette phase où
justement on est on a la chance entre
guillemets gtx est une chance en 2018 de
ne pas avoir d'échéances électorales on
à 7,7 ce temps qui nous est donné
d'abord pour faire un bilan de ce qui
s'est passé dans les campagnes
précédentes pour préparer les suivantes
mais pato en pensant à des postes en
pensant à des idées qui sont apportées
et après la question des postes c'est
celle de savoir quelles sont les
personnes qui sont les mieux à même de
défendre les idées que nous voulons
mettre en avant et c'est comme ça que
j'envisage en tout cas mon engagement
merci beaucoup le refus d'avoir
participé à ce café politique merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
et